foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on you guys sorry about
that I had a little bit of technical
difficulties you know we're gonna act
like that never happened there I never
have issues We're Gonna Act Like That
Never Happened let me raise this up a
little bit
what's going on you guys
Lord out of here
appreciate you guys coming through
another attic show of the past present
future game I got my co-host with me
Dirk gergy what's going on dirt what's
up my brother
we got let's talk about today man yeah
yeah I'm loving it gotta upset some
people you know we got the Xbox game
pass core I think me and dirt might I
think me and Dirk might disagree a
little bit when it comes to that I saw
your tweets I saw your tweets that we're
gonna disagree
a little bit a little bit then we got
Xbox by take two Interactive
you know Dustin made some uh pretty
strong statements over there at uh on
the iron Lords podcast so we gotta talk
about that and then we're gonna talk
about that Xbox and ABK update we've
actually had some uh pretty
you know substantial updates going on
when it comes to that but appreciate you
guys coming through uh we're gonna go
ahead and get to what we've been playing
during what you've been playing what
you've been on them sticks with man I
finally finished
Gotham Knights
it's not bad it's not bad it's not great
well it's not bad
um finish that one uninstalled it you
know when I asked you started playing
because I'm going to go back to Star
Wars Jedi Survivor I actually started
playing like oh yeah no oh no no
Survivor oh Survivor yeah that's
Survivor yeah do you know what I started
playing yesterday just because I was
going through my library
Splinter Cell conviction
conviction
yeah they upscaled it to 4K it's
definitely 4K still you know it's still
like 360 Graphics but it definitely
upskilled it and you know I love
something to my Xbox I don't know if
we're going to talk about all of the you
know pods being BC all of the Splinter
Cell games are are Bagless compatible
all of them from the X the original Xbox
into the Xbox 360 all of this Planet
Cell games are backers compatible and I
have all of them and there's some great
games bro oh yeah we could talk about
that a little bit let me
make that a topic here
you know my first topic was going to be
the cause situation I mean uh Xbox core
but we'll talk about Call of Duty and
backwards compatibility in general
um
and BC so I'm sure a lot of you have
seen that the Call of Duty
games have like skyrocketed I think
someone said that um
it's like a ridiculous like all of them
are like the top selling things that's
on that's crazy that's on Xbox right now
and you know what's crazy about that
that's even that if you really think
about it makes it even worse
none of those games are on PlayStation
currently
yeah you know it's it's it's crazy Addy
because you know I know some like some
people might say aha y'all are hyping up
older games but no that's not the point
the point is that
sometimes each and every one of us we
have a little bit of nostalgia right
whether it's for movies music or
whatever just like if you have Spotify
you can go back and listen to some music
from your childhood no problem
I think it's cool for people that grew
up on the 360 playing card on the 360.
they can go back
and play it man and you don't have to
have a 360. you can play it on your
current Xbox that's what that's cool I
mean that's a cool option for me the
fact that I could play all three fables
from the 360 era
and hell man if you want there's
original Xbox game on that like just
chat just think about that you know just
close your eyes without it and just
think about
the fact that you could play all the way
back to the original Xbox game 20 years
ago yeah
and if I remember correctly I don't know
because I never used the uh the feature
because I don't really have original
Xbox games like that
I could put the disc in there
yeah you can put the disc in bro just
think about that you can
you could go to eBay right now and buy a
game that's supported on Xbox series
platforms that's on the original Xbox
and throw that sucker straight in the in
the console if he's playing console and
we've seen people post videos or tick
tocks of them doing exactly that
they have their physical copy they pull
a little help put it in the Xbox series
X and they was ready to go it booted
right up you know after it installed
yeah and my brother the funny thing is
my brother he's been playing the uh
Black Ops Zachary what Black Ops have
you been playing
what Black Ops have you been playing
he's been playing Black Ops one and two
um
you just
I know that people don't think that's a
big deal
but that's a big deal and especially Tom
Henderson kind of like alluded that that
Xbox and Microsoft pushed them to fix
those servers
yeah so if that is the case that's big
that's genius marketing
absolutely bro well I read that
Microsoft was the ones that fixed the
servers I couldn't find the article
saying that word okay but I found a
tweet of Tom Henderson giving the credit
to Microsoft so yeah it's just like you
know what's funny you know what's funny
those those games have been messed up
for years those servers I thought I
thought I thought Microsoft and Xbox
weren't going to help at all like they
they are helping the Cod Community and
they haven't even bought the company yet
yeah right and not just that I don't
know if this was a topic but I know you
saw that at division blizzard games and
blizzard games are going to go um to
steam
I don't know if you saw that you know
yeah they're already they're already
giving the games to more communities you
know yeah
the PC people if they're weird and
they're fickle you know if you don't
they love steam they don't like nothing
to them if you don't abide to their will
they have no problem
boycotting you review bombing you in
some cases threatening you
you know but Microsoft see the light a
long time ago when they try to make
stuff exclusive to the Windows store and
it didn't work out so they're like let's
just put it on Steam that's kind of been
Microsoft's thing for the longest time
we're gonna go over the actual games are
you know game we're gonna go where they
are so that makes perfect sense let's
get these Super Chat because Nintendo is
people ever born done started all kinds
of foolishness on Twitter today
Oscar will uh Oscar wheat with the two
dollar super charge GTA been on Game
Pass two times now could this be a sign
we'll get to that we'll get to that oh
two dollars from Nintendo Dom the ataku
addict tears of the Kingdom link clears
Cloud easily I disagree I I disagree so
much you have no I it I would love
I would love for someone to explain to
me
how tears of the Kingdom link that runs
out of energy in like half a mile
running
is going to take out cloud
that has literally took on armies
and people's like but addict first off
leak's sword the master sword repels
evil
it will cut stuff but its powers won't
work on cloud it's not like it's he he's
it's literally going to be a sword
fighting cloud and if we've seen
multiple times the master sword has
broke
a few times
so it it's like
I get it
whoever thinks Cloud would lose to link
and the people like the shoe the shoe
so Hyrule Shield let me get this [__] I
have no opinion on this topic so someone
is going to be able to take the shield
and rotate someone that can move that
fast like it it doesn't matter how much
the shield takes damage and let's let's
not act like
The Shield is it like the nlb-all thing
you know I remember a screw attack used
to act like his lock-on thing was like
that's a game mechanic that's not a
skill you know what I'm saying like it
technically Final Fantasy you walk onto
the characters 24 7. so it's the same
thing
there is no world even a little bit
where link claps cloud
you run a hundred simulation
cloud is going to be Link at least 90 of
them
but that's my rant that's my rent we're
gonna uh you know I I think backwards
compatibility
it was definitely good it is cool it is
seeing that you know focusing on those
older things it was so powerful when
they got backwards compatibility what
happened Dirk Sony had a pop-up and say
can I copy your homework but not make it
look obvious like
look man backwards compatibility is what
I always say it's better to need it and
not have it than to
um to hold on it's better to have it and
not need it than it needed and not have
it yeah yeah
in the end
you know when you could play these older
games it matters you know it and what's
funny is it's like do we have I really
took advantage of like the backwards
kind of compatibility a lot no but if I
wanted to ever at any time Jump on and
play the original fables I can I could
play all the Call of Duties I could do
that like if you really want to get
technical the only place you could do
all that's on an Xbox you can't do that
on Playstation they don't have backwards
compatibility like that
no I told you uh a few months ago I went
back and finished Max Payne one and two
on the original Xbox because I never
finished those games back in the day I
finished both of them
and if you look at it from this
standpoint too where it's like you know
not only do these games run
on the series snx they run better than
they did on their predecessors yep it's
just it's unavoidable man is it a
feature that is that we need no but it's
a feature that if you bought a game 15
years ago you shouldn't be locked out of
it
especially when we got a show to these
console manufacturers when they make the
next Xbox I don't care I want backwards
compatibility and if you cave now
they're not going to put the r d to make
sure it works and that's that's the
point it's like why do people encourage
companies to give us less access to the
games that we bought I don't understand
it
all right so that's pretty much all I
had on that is there anything else you
want to talk about when it comes to that
nah man just that's that is a cool
feature and it's cool to see Call of
Duty I do want to say one quick thing
excuse me I remember when the activism
blizzard deal was first announced
some PlayStation fans were kind of
saying that Xbox had nothing to do with
this with the success of Call of Duty
and everybody that was around know that
when Call of Duty blew up it was on the
Xbox 360. even though it was available
for the PS3 also it blew up on the Xbox
360 bro yeah someone said leak is a
buster and Cloud sort is literally the
Buster sword fight over
cloud
yeah Link's been chasing the same one
for like two decades
two dollar super trap for max city in uh
and Xbox been catching dub after dub I
love being about yeah yeah they they Max
Cindy what's up bro they've definitely
been doing really good let's move on to
the first dub well it's kind of a
you might give it a dub I ain't give it
a dub uh we we got the Xbox game pass
core now for those of you that don't
know Xbox Gold's been around forever and
no one's liked it it's been like the
red-headed stepchild that everyone
ignores the family cookouts and it was
renamed to an entry edition of Game Pass
called Game Pass core
what's your first and obviously you see
my video so it's kind of cheating
because you know what my opinion is uh
what is your opinion on this matter
um
I think core is okay
um console tier and I think that's like
a waste
um but I think the core tier is fine
um
they have the ultimate so they have core
they have consoles here they have
ultimate and what's the other one isn't
it four different tiers those are three
different tiers now I think it okay so
it was the core Game Pass
and ultimate I think it was three no PC
game pass was the fourth one okay and
you know we could um about that too you
know once again
they I don't know if it's new but they
added EA play to PC game pass
yeah it was always ultimate
um regular PC game pass oh okay okay so
yeah yeah you can get EA access to it uh
and to me that's some sucker [__] likes
well like I I always say man this has
been going on for years PC
Gamers get more advantages than console
Gamers I mean that's that's like paying
taxes is something you don't like you
don't want to do but it's gonna happen
you know it's inevitable so it's you
know it is what it is man I can't
explain why
this is how it is but as far as the
tears I I do like options but I think
the console tier is useless well the
other ones they're finding me can you
tell me like exactly
um what was the issue that you have with
it so my issue with the core is I'm
looking at this is
Once Upon a Time gold was just
subservist no one wanted
but we had to pay for
but it wasn't part of the geek that the
Game Pass structure so you can't really
compare the two there were two different
separate
systems two different separate services
but then they decided to make it that
game pass core and to me that's
screaming an entry version of Game Pass
would you not agree
sure it's kind of like the elite
controller core if you want to get the
elite controller with some of the
accessories you can but if you want to
upgrade that and get the actual PC uh
the actual Elite controller too it comes
with everything
but it's like when you upgrade from the
core you the core you have online
so let's say okay you want to upgrade
get you you want to play one of the
games in Game Pass or one of the games
you get maybe seed thieves I don't know
if you particularly need uh free to play
because I don't know if that's
technically a free to play game or not
so now if you see if thieves is yeah so
if if see if these isn't a core thing
and I don't know you got to you know got
to have online
so let's say you pop in and it's not in
court and you see thieves and people and
you've been playing Call of Duty for the
past six months
and then you're like okay let me upgrade
to this next game pass because I want to
play that sea of Thieves
I want to play more card
so you upgraded now you go to play a
game and it says you need gold well
whatever it's going to say now I don't
know
to me if you have a tier system a
structured tier system
it's like patreon
when you get on the bottom tier carries
all the way up to the top chairs
it shouldn't be I pay ten dollars for
this and I upgrade and I lose a feature
I've been paying for
you know if you go and to me
there's no reason to not have the online
in the game pass that's my biggest issue
my biggest issue is you have a
structured tier system with Game Pass
Out game pass core Game Pass Game Pass
ultimate would you consider that a
structured tier system
yeah to me why is that middle tier not
have the stuff that the first here has
and they said edit you get more because
you pay more
yeah but you're paying more so you do
it's a difference between giving you
additional features for money that
you're paying more and taking features
when you was paying less from you in the
in the more advanced tiers you know
we could say what we all want about
PlayStations crazy PlayStation Plus
places essential PlayStation I need you
whatever their names are because they're
crazy to me
but they don't take anything from you
when you're upgrading to those tiers and
to me
Game Pass
is is weird how you could go into the
entry and have online and upgrade and
you know out of everything you're
thinking this is going to make it a
better service but then you play any of
those games in La online
and you gotta upgrade to the to the 15
Tier 16.99 tier to actually use the game
now
okay I'm still I'm listening to you but
I'll be right back
okay
so Xbox Live Gold they say play together
online
as well as life goal obviously that's a
check Xbox game pass or you can also do
that there
games Library two games a month with
Games with Gold
of course they got rid of that now Xbox
game pass core gives you a catalog of
over 25 high quality games and they did
say they will maybe add a few here and
there
remember deals and discounts up to 50
off of Select games
so that's the same play select fully
featured games with free to play days
that's the same
and most importantly the price is the
same
okay that's the core
um
not really seeing what they what's the
issue is with the core but addict said
the up see I need to see exactly what
every tier really
um supports so you're saying the core
tier is fine but when you upgrade it you
lose something you lose the online
feature
that's the console core right yeah
console and see people say I mean the
console tier I mean yeah people say well
addict they're just renaming Xbox Live
Gold it's nothing changed yes the name
the name changed it's no longer a goal
where it seems like some service that's
on the left
a service that we've just had to pay for
it is a service that is connected to
Game Pass now it's called Game Pass core
they literally structured
the sheet that they they showed you to
promote this feature these these tier
system as a tier system you can either
get Game Pass core Game Pass OR ultimate
that comes with PC if you're only on PC
to me if you're going to have this
structure the middle one cannot have
something the first one has if they all
three got to have it and it's just weird
that you go in there let's say the
people that you know
it's like I said I don't know CTS are in
there I didn't really look at the games
like that but you're looking at
something on Game Pass just imagine
yourself as someone that don't keep
track with everything like we do so I'm
just sitting there I see see
overcooked I don't know so you say
overcooked on there it's like you know I
want to get myself overcooked oh it's in
Game Pass I gotta upgrade from core to
Game Pass okay let's do that you know I
can play overcooked and then you go on
to play overcooked with your friend and
it says now you got to upgrade from Game
Pass to Game Pass ultimate to get online
and then they're gonna be like well I'm
confused I had online yesterday why
don't I have online now and I upgrade to
have a better experience and you're
wanting me to upgrade again to play the
games
no continue I I mean
I guess I didn't really look into this
topic deeply because I'm still trying to
understand what everything let me see
because
what
keep keep talking
Han so 100 high quality games on Console
new games day one member deals and
discounts
the PC
same thing except for EA play membership
of course ultimate
pounds we all love it right
I'm I don't know man you know like I was
in the chat tell me what I'm when I'm
well what you guys think I don't know
what the hell going on bro the only tier
I think is kind of useless is the second
here the console tier
that tier seems useless to me because
they don't it doesn't have online
that's here definitely seems useless to
me but as far as the chords here the PC
tier and the ultimate tier those tears
seem fine the console tear just seems
stupid it just seems it can't pass
without multiplayer that that tier
doesn't make sense to me but that's
that's the issue the issue is you have a
tear
first off that's more expensive than the
PC tier
you get to play the PC tier at a cheaper
cost and you get the benefits of having
you pretty much if you're not a console
gamer and you get the PC version of Game
Pass you get ultimate
besides cloud computing
right and it's just like because they
get they get EA play and it's just like
who in The Boardroom to me and it's not
even just the lack of online community
the online feature
who thought it would be a good idea to
make the the console people feel so like
not wanted oh you know on PC oh you
don't have to pay for online you know
what not only do you have to pay for
online we're going to give you
this feature we charge ultimate for but
they don't give us that
so it's just like
as a PC Gamer if you have no interest in
traveling as a mobile unit
why even upgrade to Ultimate they make
us upgrade if we want that
they make us upgrade
because PC uh Game Pass ultimate you can
argue is really only just aim towards
console players
because you you get access to online
and you get access to EA play but
you don't need you don't need online
features for for the PC version and you
get EA play so why is that even I don't
understand why people are just letting
that slip like people like games with Go
Games with Gold has been trashed for the
longest time no one cares about Games
with Gold yeah they nobody cares about
that but see that was one of the things
they always like really
got you in going with you know okay
you're paying for ea uh you're paying
for the online version because the games
with gold forget uh gay uh for you know
Game Pass I think
Game Pass core Xbox game pass core is
the right step in the right direction to
replacing Xbox Live Gold
I just don't like how you open up with
the first tier
and then when you want to upgrade to
that Xbox game pass to get something
that's of a multiplayer faction in there
like I said see these without a sudden
they're overcooked there's a lot of
multiplayer Central games in there
they're gonna make you upgrade again
to play online
I get you okay okay I I totally
understand you now I get what you're
saying because at first I was a little
bit confused because I didn't know
exactly what every tier included now I'm
looking directly at it there's four
tiers
the chords here is the one you said
you're okay with it but if you want to
play uh you know some if you want if you
want to get Game Pass you move to the
console tier but then they take away the
multiplayer
there's that's what you're saying right
so then you have to get ultimate anyway
I understand what you're saying I agree
with you on that like I said the
consults here
is only for I saw somebody in the chat
say the console tier is only for
maybe some parents that kids don't play
online they don't want their kids to
play online that's the only reason I can
see why the console tier
is useful
um
so I I understand what you're saying now
because because like to me core is
pretty much the same thing as lie it's
except for they took away those trash uh
would you call them uh games would go
and they included 25
games right so yeah I understand what
you're saying now because at first I was
a little confused about what your
complaints were but I get it now so yeah
but so actually we pretty much agree
that the consul tears needs to is
useless right yeah because those four
tiers look if they just put the the
online in the middle tier would make
sense the biggest feature I have is like
you shouldn't be trying to Captivate and
capitalize on this middle tier that
doesn't even feel like the value it
because and then if you look at the
difference between core and Game Pass
besides the extra games which they said
they're giving you 25 games I'm very
curious what those 25 games are you know
what I'm saying like I don't know if
they gave you a whole list or anything
like that you could argue if you like
those 25 games enough you don't even
have to upgrade to Game Pass
like if you want to play game if you
want to have access to the Game Pass
library and play online you have to go
from the ten dollar to the 16 tier or
you're not doing that
you have to
I got you I got you hey man somebody
said there's only three tiers they're
like realski no there's four I'm looking
directly at it I just sent it to attic
if you can pull it up I'm looking
directly at his four tiers
now someone said the consult here is is
like the one that we're questioning he
said maybe that's what people that just
want to get something like Starfield you
know they want to get a game and game
pass but they don't want to play it
online so at the end of the day they're
all options you know they're options
um I I guess if you change your mind if
you got the courts here or whatever tier
you got and some things change
I guess they're not giving you much of
an option except for to upgrade to
Ultimate so all right so I have them up
so let's let's go over this because some
people are like disagreeing with you in
a way
and uh you know let's go over the actual
facts here all right so let me
first off let me turn off this Xbox
because I turned on this headset and now
I hear people spamming me or something
all right
so you got the core online console
multiplayer catalog of over 25 high
quality games on Console member deals
and discounts that is gold
but instead of the the games with gold
will go it's got the catalog over 25
games that that is a better deal than
Games with Gold
okay especially if they can rotate that
every couple months and give you maybe
a year from now they put Starfield in
there instead you know what I'm saying
that's good no issue with that potential
first off I do think that needs to be a
little cheaper the the difference
between those two considering it kind of
I don't know it's weird to me uh you see
like Netflix and stuff I don't know but
you go to the console when hundreds of
high quality games new games on day one
member deals and discounts
so that's fine it's just that online
that online the online away right it's
gone so now it's like I said let's say
you looked in there let's say CDs isn't
one of those 25 games I don't know yeah
we can name any multiplayer games
there's Elder Scrolls Online there's a
lot of games in PC and Game Pass and
you're looking at that and be like yo
your friend's like yo man come in here
and play this with me you upgrade from
the core version to the console game
pass because that's how they're going
they either want you to go to game pass
or Game Pass ultimate
uh so you upgraded that and then you go
to play the game with them and it's like
yo we need you to have it on online
subscription
adding but this is the thing though this
is this is like the more I'm looking at
this the more I'm starting to understand
a little bit better
first off Microsoft is uh not going to
babysit you you have to read if you're
one upgrading to multiplayer you gotta
you gotta read it you can't just go to
console and
um seeing there's no multiplayer now
what's what's happening in my eyes
console is an option
because somebody said in the chat
console appears to be option for
something like Starfield
if you just want to get Game Pass games
day one that you don't care about
playing online that's an option that's
what I'm getting now
that's the option
um but the option for ultimate if you
want everything you have it right there
for 16.99 so I'm just starting to
understand it's more of an option
um and the auction's fine but the thing
I don't like is like to me this core
I wish I had
do I have this open I do
hold up
you know we we about to go to art art
school okay we about to go to Art School
and I don't know why it's messed up like
this
all right there we go oh you guys should
see it now
or you don't it keeps me no we don't
know all right we'll just do this that's
fine all right so
let me first off let me grab that
coffee
let's go back
here's here's my thing
I just don't like how
it left again oh there it is can you
guys see this fine now you can see it
now okay I don't like how this system
here you get into this and you have all
these people get into this because they
converted them from gold
okay
so they're not used to this system
they're just used to just having the
online and the deals for to a degree you
know there's probably a bunch of people
that do that and it's just like okay
it's like I said you see those games all
game pass because I'm sure they're going
to promote the hell out of them and then
they're like okay let's go ahead and
come over here to this to regular game
pass it's like I said then they get into
that one game that all they friends are
playing and like you could play it but
you have to come all the way over here
to Ultimate oh yeah like but if you have
friends that's on PC game pass to make
it even worse they playing all that for
free like
laughs
so okay your complaint is
when you upgrade to the next tier
you you lose something which is
multiplayer I I agree with that
but
I guess what it is they you hit you have
to
yeah I see what you're saying because
it's actually a dollar more but I
mentioned the the console tier I don't
like the consult here I don't like these
people in the chat saying it's not new
game pass core is new it's just used to
be gold
okay the div the name is different when
it was gold you never connected it to
Game Pass
but now it's called Game Pass core it's
different
but you still don't get Game Pass though
but the name and I get that but the
names everything like when back in it
used to be called gold you wouldn't
expect
uh you wouldn't expect the the online
subscription for this because it was
called something else but now they have
a tier system which choose what plan
fits you the best right here they're
they're promoting it like a like a
tiered system so now you got all these
core members you know we got the core
members and then they're like okay you
know I want to play C of Thieves
and then guess what now Microsoft has
they wallet open again and they're like
look man I know you just upgraded to get
this to play the seat these with your
friends but we got some bad news for you
in order to play that you gotta upgrade
to ultimate
but if your friend that's playing the
same game and cross cross play on PC
don't gotta do none of that stuff
okay Attic So all it is is you have to
upgrade if you want okay if your friend
is playing see if these or your friend
obviously has Xbox game pass ultimate so
you have to upgrade to what your friend
has that's it but but that's all I'm
saying and I get that and it's it's like
that for everyone so it's not like
certain people get it I mean you could
argue that the people in PC and I think
that is a legit argument that needs to
be had like this PC
pass right here is [__] likes like
the fact that like I'm sorry like okay
let's
let's keep this a buck dirt all right
you see you see this EA this EA
membership you see this right here
yeah that needs to be gone all right
you should make if we gotta pay for that
they gotta pay for that all right and
see oh I'm about to go go to grade
school with you guys you see this right
here see this right here this needs to
be copied and pasted and it needs to be
put here
all right this is the way this this is
the way all right this is the way this
is how this this Fiasco actually you
know what and on top of that we need to
put that on the PC one too all right
this this is how this is how it needs to
be all right this is the one that's how
we should be right that's how it should
be this this is Alex game passed here
right here Alex came first I mean we we
could call it that that's fine
okay
addicts game past years
all right
oh it's too small it's too small
I'd Escape past system
this sucks too big this is the way okay
this game pass tier system okay let's
screenshot that and put it on Twitter
this is how it should be actually
yo uh
if I actually I I would change another
thing but I don't think it's like
serious I do think this core system
should be a little bit cheaper but that
that's besides the fact that that's
that's semantics at that point so look
what the course should be eight ninety
nine don't forget they just went up on
Game Pass pricer oh but that looks like
a Game Pass that's right yeah Sam yeah
ladies and gentlemen is added y'all
at least
yeah that's how it should be and you
guys know I'm right all right you guys
might come in here do your Hold the Line
TV shirts and stuff like that but
you guys know that I'm right and the
added Game Pass tier system should be
the only system that exists all right
you know what I just did there I made it
fair it doesn't matter if you play on
Xbox PC
you gonna get the same one that the last
dude got all right you know some people
in here sitting to say Daddy don't
matter PC don't play for online and why
is that okay it matters right in a
single
magnificent five minutes
I turned game pass into what it should
be not what it is
what it should be
I'm actually going to post that on
Twitter later
shout out to Addie oh man why is someone
always lurking by an attic let me read
these super chats you guys are
ridiculous oh my God but I appreciate
you guys uh
uh
coming in with my shenanigans
look it doesn't matter to me in the end
but I don't like it I do think that that
shouldn't be like that
um
just it's fine man we know we disagree
it's not a big deal yeah we don't
disagree I'm just right and you're just
wrong yeah yeah we're gonna disagree but
I mean you can disagree with the Xbox
that's fine
uh okay so gamer by choice is the five
dollar Super Chat appreciate the
generous donation the reason people hate
backwards compatibilities because they
do not have it just like quick resume
and laying games on Xbox uh Lane games
on Xbox and PC for first party
gonna be something Nintendo related
Nintendo has four exclusives this year
rated higher than the highest rated
exclusive on Xbox and Playstation 5.
just wanted to put out there you know we
don't know what that Starfall gonna be
stop I was able to say Starfield hasn't
come out yet I just want to point that
out you know what Nintendo I just want
to point out that that uh I'm pretty
sure that Zelda it it wasn't as high as
breath of the wild wasn't it I'm pretty
sure it went down didn't it
don't quote me on that but I'm pretty
sure Zelda's was a lower Metacritic
score but you know it is what it is uh
so like I said don't quote me on that
though the new gamer plus with the two
dollars super Jack core includes
multiplayer for 9.99 no that's not the
argument two dollar super trap from
jax82 it's just
it's just like the 30 frames argument
go to PC
no it's not because they're paying for
initially the same product that we get
but they don't have to pay for EA play
and they also don't have to pay for
online it's not the same thing
Alvin with the five dollar Super Chat
the core people looking to upgrade will
go straight to Ultimate people will read
what's in what plan
take it from someone that did customer
service in Dish Network for two years no
that's not the case
that is definitely not the case
uh we got two dollar Super Chat for uh
uh the core people uh five dollar
commissioner from the angry therapist MD
I hope they fixed this but me personally
I have ultimate I hear you man I hear
you two dollar super trap from uh Obama
what I'm just gonna Butch your name man
uh it's core 68 I don't know if you can
buy like okay right now you might be
able to do it because they're still
converting it but I'm curious if they're
going to allow you to buy that 60 a year
when the actual core gets converted
by the way Polly Papa uh Keel Walker
with the 25 months member chat you could
still pay 60 year for One Core tier the
25 games are on the Xbox blog oh I
didn't know that someone uh someone hit
me up with that man someone hit me up
with that
all right so let's let's go ahead and
move on with this let's move on that was
a pass in the topic man yeah yeah you
know the the chat gonna clown on me I
got a clown on myself sometimes 46 we
saw the addict here I like the addict
here
Xbox buying take two interactive man
what's what's going on with this first
off do you believe this and I'm gonna go
check out my brother why you answer that
oh no no I don't believe it um were
there discussions probably possibly
um but I don't believe it was I mean
listen man let's be real guys
nobody thought the activism blizzard
will get purchased by anyone let alone
Microsoft
Activision Blizzard is the biggest
third-party developer but you better
believe take two is right there because
they have pretty much the biggest
um game
do they need to get acquired of course
not
um but we thought the same with activism
blizzard but I don't I don't think so
especially not
after this whole Fiasco with ABK bro
it's like ah come on man
like them buying take two
they could not make GTA exclusive
nowhere in the world they don't really
make a lot of other games so it's like
uh I mean GTA is a huge brand of course
but
I just I don't see it I don't see it I
see after this APK deal is 100 final
they will buy more Studios I'm not sure
if they'll get another publisher if they
do get a publisher I think it would be
probably Sega most likely just my
opinion but I don't see take two but I
just don't see it
okay but then again I've never seen I
didn't see activism blizzard either so
I don't put too much thought process
into this I'm sure they have talk to
take too
I don't know
if the conversations they had would take
two was was to the point where here's
the thing
it don't matter who the hell they talk
to
before they they bought ABK it matters
since they talked to after they bought
ABK they don't realize how much
difference is going to be going into
buying another big publisher with ABK
behind you
it was different when it wasn't behind
you but now it is behind you and people
are going to look at that was like look
you bought a big publisher year six
months a year year and a half ago now
you're coming into this new thing and
you want us to okay you buying another
big publisher and keep in mind these
Publishers they ain't cheap they just
know like at 50 billion Microsoft got it
most likely yeah we got it yeah it's not
going to hurt them too much and you know
especially have a GTA I think that's the
way they're doing they're looking at
these big
Publishers and they're like look
we were we're looking at you for a
couple games because we want those games
on Game Pass
but we're also eyeballing what you have
that could easily be exclusive it
wouldn't matter
so they look into something like
Activision Blizzard King they're like I
think that was the best studio they
could ever buy was that studio because
they wanted so much from that studio
but I do think they're looking at you
know stuff now and it's like look you
know
Activision we Call of Duty we're gonna
put Call of Duty on Game Pass day and
day
um
bad crash
that's us that's that's mine the spiral
that's mine
and then in 10 years when they had this
conversation they're like you was
talking to extra last month
you talk way too much crap yeah you're
right about that
um but the ABA thing uh I mean not the
APK thing to take two things out I don't
see that
because like I said if they did buy them
they could not and I repeat could not
make GTA exclusive I mean they could but
they wouldn't that game is way too
massive uh that game is huge
um if you have a game that came out 10
years ago that's still in the top 10
every month in npds that's crazy man
um
so yeah but I do want to say this right
quick at it I think in the future
who knows you know King Dave always say
there's not going to be a PlayStation 6.
what if in the future I don't know apple
or Amazon or somebody buys PlayStation
or some other system comes out Xbox is
putting themselves in a great position
by buying activism blizzard by buying
Bethesda some other Studios to where
they don't have to
I mean they own activation Blues I mean
they own Call of Duty so that game
outside of PlayStation and Nintendo for
the next 10 years and and the cloud
services they're not obligated to put
that game or any other system
in the future outside of 10 years and I
don't know say a PlayStation gets bought
by someone
does that contract still stand I don't
know but
Xbox is putting themselves in a great
position with this the people they have
acquired from
I agree I think when it comes to take
two look take two might be someone
they're looking at and maybe Microsoft
is willing to
you know risk some of their money to buy
something like that uh take two but to
me
you know to me it looks like they barely
got ABK
yeah oh yeah yeah it was a fight brother
let me just realistically we are not
lawyers and we're not judges was it
really a fight
I mean if you look at it they only
delayed it like what two months
yeah because they still did have to
delay because of the CMA they had
technically they had to delay it so that
lets me know that uh because the CMA
blocked it that caused the whole that
caused a lot of issues um obviously
they're pretty much passing now it's not
finalized yet but you're right uh
18 months is a long time now it's pretty
much 19 to 20 months it took to but
we're talking about buying a massive
corporation like that yeah
did they realistically take a long time
I mean if you look at it from their
standpoint they gave us a a Time range
goal
and they missed it by two months
so let me ask you again Doris yeah
that's true Did they really struggle to
get APK or was this the way the industry
normally works and it looks worse
because we never paid attention
yeah that's a good point but um
I just still feel there was some
challenges because the CMA blocked
if you know what I'm saying I think
there wasn't sure even people it was
like hogloss said that that's common
oh is it okay
yeah I guess so
yeah so it is to me when it comes to
that
okay yeah it comes to that it's like
if they buy them they buy them if they
don't I agree with you I think they're
going to keep it because I think hogloss
said usually above 10 billion dollars is
when everyone starts looking at them
like crazy I think they'll keep it below
that 10 billion
you know they don't want I mean they
don't want too many of you know power
struggles looking at they stuff with
side eyes I think yeah for the most part
they'll look at it oh can we get Sega
for 7 billion
pop that up put that on the back man oh
banana put that on the back too
they just take a truck up to up to the
acquisition office they're just looking
around put that in the back of the truck
right and then it's like they had all
these these
these car they had all these these
companies in the back of the truck and
they came across APK
it's like one of those things where you
look at it it's like I could put some of
these back I could I could get a bigger
truck we could go get this you know
Bethesda was a flash still we could get
this they put Sega back because like
we'll come back for you Pat them on the
bat on the top of the head and then they
just throw Warner Brothers back and was
like if you if you're there you're there
hmm
it's like it's like Crystal Dynamics
like the little cat they just yeah it
was like running around the the the shop
they're like I was just about to say
that because I know King Dave says it
all the time I'm expecting after this
deal is finished within the next few
months after that they're going to pick
up AV uh 90k crucial Dynamics how those
Montreal they're already working on Xbox
games you might as well make an official
all these Acquisitions back to back yeah
hey man why do you talk about my head
man they said I got Ray tracing man come
on man this is attic show why y'all
talking bad about me man you know
they're gonna do that
we got a five dollar Super Chat from oh
I will read Corey Tidwell yeah oh I'm
sure you will these messages
yeah he said your boy thrash is doing
jig analysis
and giganomics is wild [__] Sony in the
driver's seat with 30 70 ain't enough to
sustain Game Pass yeah yeah man I've
seen a bunch of stuff like that
people saying that uh Xbox got a worse
deal with PlayStation which is
absolutely unbelievable for them to even
uh fix their lips to say some stuff like
that but yeah it's it's ridiculous man
um maybe I can do something for you
spotting 661 with the five online needs
to be in all tears because it's rough in
these subscription streets
there are so many and they need to fight
for your hard-earned cash
yeah if you're in that core system you
upgrade to a higher tier I just don't
like they take features from you it just
sits wrong with me and especially
something as poor is as important as an
online structure to be able to play
online
and I could I can guarantee you there's
going to be a lot of scenarios where
people upgrade with a game a particular
game of mine because they're playing
online now people's like addict addict
read it's like I said you'd be surprised
I did two years of customer service at
Dish Network you'd be surprised in how
critical thinking is a very lacked term
okay people don't know what they're
going on with that people will sit there
and call me and and complain about a
bill they clearly did like I've had to
literally spend an hour going over
item by item bill by Bill to make them
understand you know you know it's funny
when I did uh because I went through
something called uh retention training
it's where they uh teach me how to
remain calm how to how to reverse the
conversation how to throw the
conversation on the customer yeah you
know how many times I had to the biggest
thing they always tell you when you're
talking to angry people that are upset
about a bill it's like blame them
it's like so you go over there and it's
like you know they got a 20 surge
protector when the the tactician came in
this is a twenty dollar so did you buy
that sir
uh yeah did you sign this piece of paper
agreed you I know how much this cost
yeah but they didn't tell me so you you
want me
to be mad because you didn't read like
it's funny man
yeah
uh thank you therapist with the five
they're they're going to buy Namco and
bring home Ridge Racer
I remember that uh that's such a
terrible E3 for Sony that year Timba
with the two pounds what y'all think of
James Gunn game movie Titan I don't know
what to talk about I don't want that the
game talk about that because
I don't want like a giant side scroll
like we'll end up getting off topic how
I think Xbox needs a Congo book hero and
dirt that they don't so
I personally feel like they should be
hitting them up getting in that DC from
the ground floor but dirt thinks it's
not that seriously
timbuk with another two pounds I
personally think forcing tie-in is a bad
idea James Gunn I didn't mean so like he
said something about it by the game with
the movie time I didn't hear that yeah
well what's going on right now is
James Gunn's like DC Universe the games
tie in with all the movie stuff it's all
it's all one more
okay yeah imagine it's like the MCU with
games too and not just movies do you
know I still think the best movie to
game tie-in even though the game wasn't
that great but if the but the tie-in was
really good was entered the Matrix
the PS2 and the original Xbox that was a
great tie-in even though like I said uh
it was you know the game wasn't that
great but the tie-in was yeah all right
so
I think we're done with this topic
unless there's anything you want to
random let's move on brother let's go to
50 59 minutes for the timestamp police
I got the time steps good this week
sometimes I'll forget the first topic
and I'll just throw like a rant okay I
think we've been talking about this for
15 minutes I'm gonna go 15 minutes back
and I occasionally I'll get a call with
it's like you you timestamp the middle
of the conversation hey but I got close
oh yes all right so APK and Xbox you
know normally I don't want to talk about
this but it's people sit there and they
say they don't want to talk about the
ABK deal but how is my best videos that
ABK do because people want to talk about
it bro people want to hear about it and
first off I want to shout out to
everyone that's been supporting my my
channel like my personal channel is
doing really well I know yours is doing
good too dirt like you know we we out
here we out here in these streets yeah
man it's just a lot of positive Xbox
news right now so it's really helping
man
yeah dirt Mize will be in the gaming
Purge at the moment like he he started
the purge with like a machete that has
like a an Xbox symbol and he just
looking for though he looking for
everyone yeah like he's like oh I found
it he's just sitting there like some of
your videos I just lose it it's like you
have all the receipts in the world and
you just save the receipts for a video
it's like oh you talking [__] today I
got like no seats on you
I'd say them for years I'm going to say
this because I know you know you pay
attention to the console but you try not
to get involved with it today's
narrative oh man oh it actually was
yesterday's just I did a video about it
today it was the funniest narrative that
they're saying that PlayStation Showcase
in May wasn't that was a fake showcase
and the real showcase is going to be in
August I see a fake showcase or I've
never heard that that's a new narrative
for me a fake showcase but I'm sorry bro
let's get to this
yeah so yeah
we'll we'll get into that so obviously
there's been a lot of you know Justice
that's happened here recently one thing
that happened is
you know I think the last time we talked
so let me look seven days
it looks like the last time we talked to
I don't think ABK
I I think they just
disapproved it didn't they like I don't
know the uh last week we talked to I
think the Judge had uh blocked the the
ftcpi that was that was last week
last Wednesday yeah no that happened
Tuesday but we talked about it Wednesday
of course it wins the ABK okay so it's
officially
uh been blocked by everything now not
just one particular judge that's been
blocked by everything awesome yeah
because the FTC filed filed an appeal
and that was denied also yeah yeah
I still can't get that individual Center
saying you are oh and four why should we
trust you with your job oh yeah well
it's a terrible they was killing her
you could say that same thing about King
thrash
oh look oh snap
when it comes down to it you know you
look
you look about the semantics of the
thing uh the moment that happened
PlayStation signed the deal
the CMA was like we could figure
something out the one with the FTC lost
that appeal yep and yeah and let's be
right here those those
the FTC had some serious PlayStation
lobbyists backing them right and 100 it
didn't work and after they realized the
FTC was going to not win that they they
was on the phone yo what can we get and
Jim Ryan kind of played himself a little
bit because originally Jim Ryan and
Playstation could have signed a deal
that was all Activision games all ABK
doe now
it's it's like I wonder I want to see
the room that that happened at that call
where it's like ABK you know that
happens and and Jim obviously we got
those emails that leaked the show Jim
was confident at first and then I think
he started making a couple comments and
I think he started seeing the amount of
you know waves he was starting so that's
when he went from we're not signing [__]
we're getting this blocked
and I wonder if he like guaranteed those
people that that wouldn't happen like he
he looked at them and said yo you know
PlayStation might have want to sign it
and he's like I think we can get this
deal blocked I don't think we have to
resort to that and imagine him coming
back at Xbox and Playstation in there
and their lawyers and Playstation
looking and that news feel
I noticed it just says Call of Duty
games
what happened to our Alaska
we threw it out when you didn't sign it
right we didn't sign it man
um so now it's not good he played
himself because he got a worse deal
yep he had a worse deal like you said
those emails came out that he was like
yeah it's it's just a playful mobile all
the duties not leaving PlayStation and
then you see throughout the year
throughout last year all of a sudden
um we don't want this like we don't want
to sign a deal we want our merger block
so at the end at the end of the day he
have faith in The Regulators to block
the deal and they couldn't get it done
so he bent the knee to say you know what
the judge is like your money isn't
accepted here get out of here bro
imagine in a PlayStation if they did pay
lobbyists to Lobby against that and they
they're like they're going back and like
yeah it didn't work what you mean it
didn't work we gave we paid for your
next three elections like
the gambling PlayStation it never always
works like right
so it's
um you know I'm just glad it's coming to
an end
the only reason this delayed of course
is because of the CMA who uh Jim Ryan
convinced the blocking
they blocked it but they're talking now
and um they're going to get a deal man
you know Xbox of course had Xbox and ABK
of course had to uh sign an extension
um the extension I think is to October
or something but that was for cushion
they said that pretty confident it would
be done before the end of August
um a lot of people saying the world even
Bobby kotec said he don't see why it
can't be done in the next 45 days
so yeah they're they're going to get the
deal done and um we're going to be free
of this news
very interesting stuff man a lot of
receipts a lot of stuff happened over
these last 18 months a lot of people
showed their true colors
um after we've seen Xbox you know it's
it's just strictly you know because the
Xbox is buying this company we've heard
new narratives organic growth I never
heard that in my life until this ABK
thing organic growth
what they should be less focused on
organic growth and more focus on organic
money because Sony don't got a lot of
that it's Max man you know but this
court case Advocate has uh brought a lot
of stuff to our attention man about you
know PlayStation aggressive marketing
deals on Playstation no signing these
third-party deals did not want these
games to go to Xbox and you know that's
aggression that's business but when Xbox
is being aggressive you know they're
buying the whole publisher and they
don't like that and um you know so
that's what I've been seeing that's
that's been very interesting showing
showing people True Colors out here in
these video game streets but Xbox is um
yeah they're going to finish this deal
man within the next month
so I'll be happy it'll be over with yeah
I hear you guys I think to me I'd just
be glad when this is over you know ABK
has been good to make content with but
it's not fun to talk about
you know the only reason I make ABK
content is because I know my community
wants to be updated on it but I
unless like
I really enjoyed
court hearing and the discovery from the
court it was good it was good that was
the only time I was like that's the only
time I've ever told Cog we gotta talk
baby
yeah it was good stuff though wasn't it
man
I don't know if you was able to actually
listen to it because there were some
people that had some links I was
listening to it that was some
interesting stuff man especially when
Phil Spencer was on the stand when Jim
Ryan was on the stand Jim yes and his
was ridiculous yeah bro you said um so
many times I thought I was listening to
kids smooth
[Laughter]
uh yeah it was it was it was very
interesting man
yeah so you know um one thing I want to
point in the chat real quick because
we're about to wrap the show up uh sorry
Fame we ain't I look if we was like 15
minutes till seven I'd rock it out man
but I'm not rocking it out for 30
minutes uh but you know I want you guys
to put in the in the chat when it comes
to Planet Xbox
let me let me get this five dollar super
uh put in the chat who you guys want to
see his guests on planet Xbox keep in
mind like the Xbox guy I like to see
actual XBox guys I guess
we get Xbox guys on here I know I'm I'm
just talking trash cause y'all last
guess you know oh yeah yeah but to be
fair I've never asked you to rock with
them so yeah yeah that's cool uh final
switch out from uh from Cowboy uh Jim
Ryan what happened to the other game
Phil the other games Phil you said the
deal was inadequate here's my final best
offer the last time that's true so yeah
put in the chat let me go ahead and
switch over here for uh from funding to
live chat I just want to get an overall
feeling of who would you guys want to
see on his guest occasionally and it's
not going to be a lot like I do want to
have engaging conversations with certain
people like I have a good relationship
with like chase money and them so I
think that would be cool to have like
chase money yeah I remember chase money
yeah they have pretty good you know uh
Communications like that I'm not going
to really get PlayStation people on here
because I I don't really feel like
that's the energy I want for the attic
show
because I want this place to be uh you
know we come here we chill we kick it
and then and then we out in an hour and
a half Lulu I've actually reached out to
Lulu before
that'll be fine I have
Chase cool yeah uh I actually just got
off the phone with Chase I was talking
to him for about 45 minutes like an hour
or two ago I remember I used to watch
Chase uh Channel some years back Major
Nelson I can't here's the thing when it
comes to like guests on planet uh on uh
attic show
I have to if it's big big guest I prefer
them on IOP
frantanga
like you guys might like for tank and I
got no problem with for Tanga but I try
to stay away from like a lot of the
making you know the Fanboy video stuff
uh except for me though of course but
see there's a difference like I feel
like it's nothing against with them or
you guys do it's just like to me
you bring a lot to the table and I don't
know for Tango like that like I don't is
that the only kind of content he's
capable of making he's extremely
talented like extremely and she's like
damn man
but they do it so well it's so funny
like he's he's very good at it he's yeah
he's really good at it no doubt about it
uh we're not having Dash I think that's
what's up
that Queen trash XBox guys and not like
behind a paywall wouldn't we ever lock
anything behind a paywall
no I think he was talking about some
PlayStation guys that has certain stuff
along behind the paywall
if I'm not mistaken mads I can get mad
but I do plan on having on the patreon
having more in-depth conversations with
influencers about the state of the
gaming industry
uh and the reason I'm not putting that
on the channel is because we have new
we're actually working with uh a couple
really influencers that really know the
system
and he's giving us opinions on how we
would go about
you know structuring the channel to grow
and he doesn't want us putting more
stuff that conflicts too much like
reviews and stuff like he doesn't think
we should put a lot of like reviews that
doesn't make sense to our branding
because we want as many people to watch
them as possible and if we put like I
said I'm still going to make an attempt
a couple Nintendo reviews every year
because that we do have some people it's
like big big games I review Nintendo but
we're gonna stick mainly to Xbox and big
PlayStation games
Last of Us beer get drink no I'm not
getting Dreamcast
nothing against Dreamcast God but I just
I I just ABK Xbox acquisition is dead
I would get dark dark I'd get dark dark
what about you how do you feel about
Jeffy what about Jazzy
he's fine I guess
uh he mentioned flying at Xbox isn't
that kids yeah that's actually it's my
podcast too
uh uh yeah I'll I'll look into this fan
I'll even look at for tango and I'm not
100 not looking at everyone it's just
like trying to get people that would
vibe with me and dirt the most
so you know I have to like really gauge
his
his interest I don't know about joffy
because I know the thing between Cog and
Jaffe just happened so I'll have to see
because I'm not breeding on anyone on
this show that has beef with anyone else
on my other show I don't think that's
right
uh people really want Dreamcast guy on
here we would literally just here's the
thing
with
would Dreamcast guy
if I brought him on here
I don't know if that would be an
engaging conversation that's my only
thing like you know I don't mind
bringing people on here
like we just had calling on planet Xbox
and like you know just having him
explain more detail on his hot takes
but if I don't feel like they will
engage me and I mean Dreamcast God
probably would I just don't know if you
guys would enjoy that conversation to be
honest with you
because I feel like they think if we
bring people on here we're just going to
roast them and make them leave and cry
uh miles Don Perez he doesn't really
mess with me too much man
I could probably invite him but I don't
know there's a lot of people in this
community Fame and I'm pretty sure Dirk
will will co-sign that are very friendly
to you in your face when it's for them
coming on your platform are you helping
out with theirs but the moment you ask
anything of them they just oh we'll see
in the books oh no it's Alex I don't
know uh dirt dirt might have to upgrade
his mic yeah the ugly my mic man my mic
is a awful by the way yeah to be fair he
did he he clowned off uh on the dude we
were just talking about uh
for Tango because he has the same mic
you do
oh does he yeah so at least he's not
single one person out he clowned on
everyone I used to have that mic forever
like that Mike you have now I had for
like two or three years
yeah man it's been good to me I mean I
can upgrade if I wanted to I just I'm
fine it just I don't look I get it
extremely like
hard on
on like sound
but it's just like look will you sound
better if you upgrade absolutely do you
need it that's debatable
yeah
when I needed I would I would change it
right now is is doing fine for me I get
mad do you have a problem back
no Cliffy b i we follow each other on
Twitter but I don't know if he would
come on
I um I don't have a problem with a lot
of guys
why he flipped
yeah tell me if we got crap gamer on
here how iconic would be if we just if
we just got him to explain to us why
he's flipped back and forth from Brian
so many let me tell you something I had
brought up his name on one of my uh on
my podcast say yo guys I'm thinking
about inviting crap because I think no
like me and crab got a decent
relationship you know we're friendly we
don't talk a lot but we're friendly
and they was like hell no dirt you
better not invite that guy on wbg I was
okay okay damn okay I won't do it
plays 4K you got any problem plays
never talk to the guy yeah he is I know
he's a pony you know now there's some
ponies if you invited I probably
wouldn't come on to be honest I see but
I would never invite someone that would
make you feel like you didn't want to
come on because this is your show just
as much as it's mine I will I'm not
getting reforger and BG on here I just I
would get reforged before I got MBG and
I wouldn't know either one of them on
here surprisingly I will come on if you
got mvg but I wouldn't
why would you come up for MPG I'm kind
of curious because I still see
I still see it man ambg I think he's
starting to
kind of twist a little bit because he's
seeing some things the Xbox is doing it
with that PlayStation isn't doing what's
that like game you do when you like they
lower the the stick and you have to like
get under it every time but it's like
the Cha-Cha oh uh uh the tank is the
Tango uh or whatever they were making me
they would do a mean ass Tango man they
can bend so crazy
right Plum Plum Network I can get we've
had Plum on here before though Palm is
the dude man great guy man I'm not
bringing reforged
people just yeah Plum is a good guy
that's all they care is the smoke who's
limbo do you know who lumbo is limbo no
no no like he's he's talking about the
game
yeah yeah you're right it's called yeah
it's limbo thank you uh no it was
something like that you get shot on here
from your podcast I I wouldn't mind yeah
I gotta I got a real man say Sean no
F-bomb sir
yeah I see it my Show's a little bit
more relaxed but I don't want that on
here either you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah yes I don't I don't swear on
here you know
um
you might have you ever put my slide
into my girl's DM I can't have that oh
goodness yeah I'll look into this guys I
will I think what I'm gonna start doing
is um
they only get some influences on here
man I you know what about Colin
he's fine man
he said some questionable stuff in the
past yeah it won't happen anytime soon
because I just use that card for uh
for Planet Xbox but I'll get them on
here yeah uh bring BG on uh uh I think
Dart and BG guy he's been on here before
and I was there but second time being I
probably won't come on
no I I draw the line at Brad Pratt is
not coming up that definitely wouldn't
come on yeah
yeah I got no problem with PG BG cool
but I can understand you know hit the
way BG acts sometimes will give people
like a real
uh you know bad taste in their mouth you
know what it is I don't have a problem
with any with them either because I I
don't know him personally
yeah I wish he I wish you wouldn't have
told him that because he unbalized me
and not actually seeing his damn tweets
I'm like uh I wish people blocking me
again but I I get he's BG ain't a bad
dude like you know he's not a bag too
much sometimes yes I think he does go
extra for no reason sometimes if he
feels like if you're annoying him and he
feels like he can get one up on you he
will do he will go above Beyond it's
like that that saying on my hair
Academia
um Mighty uh mighty I actually want him
on IOP in every attempt I've reached to
try to get that dude on has failed I
could get mad I can get maddiepie he's a
pony he's a pony
the mighty Keith is a pony how do you
know
no look at his content
I feel like he
he cracks jokes but usually
he that he's throwing shots at Xbox he's
a pony I feel you I feel you if you look
at like the overall generous thing Fizz
I feel you yeah
uh
well let me see all right so that's what
I'm gonna get I'm gonna reach out to
some people you know I actually want to
you know work on some stuffer what about
Kofi
Kofi don't really mess with me like that
you know we have a we're kojo to each
other but you know I've never spoken to
Kofi I used to be subscribed I I am
still subscribed I usually listen to his
podcast back in the day trying to stop
listening to it but yeah I've never
spoken to the guy
yeah he's not a bad dude he's not I
actually seems fine you know I I hated
when Press Start went under because I
actually like that show Jack moved
Johnny
that dude was hilarious to me would you
come on if Jack move was it yeah yeah
absolutely because I actually I actually
like him bro I'm gonna have to have like
dirt send me a list of ponies he'll
actually work with
hey bone slaves that dirt cars everyone
opponent or I don't what what Mighty
Keith is it's just jokes like look I
don't really say it too much but I don't
understand why people get upset when
people say that like you know many times
I've been called an Xbox and I've never
like acted like a crazy amount of uh K
mego has been on a couple times actually
no yes okay [__] that's the homie yeah
can't make us he he family you know
actually IOP looking to do something
with K Mega here soon
XBox guys that never flip that that you
know that was their last generation
trying to do content and ponies
attacking them but they still never flip
so shout out to Kate
Mystic oh that's the PlayStation guy
he's actually really good he's the only
PlayStation Channel I'm subscribed to
because he
he's a true PlayStation fan he's not a
super fan boy
he has a good Channel Good great content
man great content oh is he a white dude
yeah it's a white guy okay I'm looking
at it now he's got decent he's got a
pretty big Channel yeah he's he that he
does a good content man good content I
don't know if I could ever like get a
hold of him
yeah who is he following he only follows
us I've never seen him on any um
high gas though
there are certain guys that like I saw
some people mention turbo reverse TV
I asked him I reached out to him like
last year he was like I'm not doing any
podcast I was like oh okay you know back
in the day
um me and smooth reached out to MBG
yeah like when he was an Xbox Channel we
reached out to him and he never came on
but yeah he he I never seen him on any
podcast besides his own
I mean there's there's guys that you
know so Mystic does follow people that I
talk to so I do have a way to reach out
to him oh I'm sorry I would say has
missed this goes on spawn cast oh okay
okay I didn't know that no that's cool
Spawn wave don't really mess with me too
much that's why like a lot everything
that plays in the chat
we're taking a play
yeah a lot of people don't know that MBG
was the Xbox Channel because I believe
he deleted on his Pro Xbox stuff or or
or unlisted it or something so that's
how I found him for taking the Xbox
channel for Tanga if I got you on the
show
now first off would you come on this
show and second off would you would you
would you not go extra on it
Erica for the wins I would never have
salty
on this show like ever
yeah yeah but do Togo is Right Salty's
and red dragon were XBox guys it's crazy
man we've had a lot of PlayStation
people that used to be um
that used to be on the other side all
right I'll I'll set that up I'ma trust
you man I'm gonna trust you because I uh
you know
I'm just I don't know you too well so I
don't like
I don't know if you could come on here
and just start being extra like you are
on your video
his videos are pretty damn good though I
Can't Live Well the one he roasted me
because he roasted me a couple years ago
when I was a much smaller Channel
but I kept on saying um yeah man the
games are coming they're coming he's
roasting me I was like damn well I
couldn't say much I think one it was
neither him or someone else that got
smooth and I got hit for collateral like
no yeah like Lionel damage yeah I got
hit for collateral nobody no I really
don't take it too personal even when
Alex uh like bashed my mic or whatever
the only thing that like Alex did is
compared you to crap camera like that
yeah my thing listen that was different
you know that was funny but when he
compared you to crab gamer I was like
come on out yeah see I'm gonna tell you
this he compared me to crap gamer but he
originally compared me to King three say
I'm the Xbox version of King thrash that
pissed me off I was like hell no
how dare you say I'm the Xbox version of
King well I mean he doesn't watch my
videos or anything I'm definitely not
crying I think he's basing that on my
intro and my intro if you love hip hop I
have some Wu-Tang Clan in my intro and a
lot of people like it
he doesn't like it and he said oh he's a
a damn crap gaming intro I was like what
but look I don't take anything personal
it's especially if it's something I've
said if if there's a tweet like for
Tanga or Alex found that I said and they
start roasting me
fair game because I put it out there but
just attacking my mic I don't really
care for that though uh here for Tega
follow me and dirt on Twitter so I can
get a hold of you
um that's pretty much all for the show
to be honest someone said Melanie Mac I
actually reached out to Melanie Mack I
got her email from her on Twitter I was
gonna get her on IOP she kind of ghosted
me
it's like you know I get really nervous
like
reaching out to chicks because like
you know right
no no Glizzy pictures right oh my God
oh I ain't go live man if I was a chick
I'd keep my DMs closed like just like
they are right now yeah yeah
I'll try to get Melody on again I'll
send her another email you know probably
not this show would probably be IOP I
like Melanie I like the content she
delivers you know I like people that are
very realistic with their approach but
sometimes they can go too far left or
too or far right and it's not even a
politic kind of thing it's just I feel
like people could you know be a little
bit more balanced I feel like there's
not enough people reaching out and
trying to officially get both sides you
know what I'm saying it's either you got
to be like right or wrong like the
majority of the answers you'll find are
more in the middle than anything
uh that that's a get Luca I don't know
you and Luca have any issues no man no
man I'm cool looking man you know that's
the girl all right so yeah I'll get I'll
get i'll get look on sometime too all
right so Dart tell the people where to
find you at man what what's what's going
on oh man nothing nothing man just um I
did a video earlier talking about uh the
guys that was saying the PlayStation
showcase was fake and the real one is
coming in August I said I will sober up
for three days to be
uh
definitely follow Dart Man follow dirt
on YouTube he's putting his stuff in
there I like to put my Twitter
information in the chat because I feel
like I feel like they can get to my
YouTube from my Twitter information you
know yeah it's definitely true I never
thought about doing it like that let me
put my Twitter in there yeah so
definitely you know hit up hit up dirt
man hit up dirt go follow him on there
here's my Twitter
uh definitely go over there and follow
them if you guys haven't followed me I
have no clue how we did it but we have
somehow
talked for 10 minutes so I guess now I I
will send you guys over there to uh
to fame unless he's not even having a
show today I didn't look I saw him in
the chat earlier
Fame
entered
why is Fame ENT I put Fame and I don't
see him right off the bat yes he will he
does have a show today uh so what's the
G over there
it is okay for Tega you know for example
I'll be sober I will put you on here and
you know it will be a trial basic man
you show up sober and you do good you
know we'll get you on IOP
you know so sometimes with the the the
real the real iffy guess you know you
got to come through here this is like
this is like the small house and IOP is
the mansion on the hill okay
but there you go
quality yeah
Ortega's has some funny videos
and now people are saying back to back
because of him everywhere yeah bro back
to back and I love how he edited it it
is just it's just crazy I'm curious in
his mind when he heard that
if that's something that he did after
when he was going through the the after
editing
or if that's something that the moment
he heard me say back to back it just
like a light bulb you know what I'm
saying yeah
yeah it was good man like I said even
even when he roasted me a couple years
ago I was like damn but it was you know
it was cool man so I'm gonna send you
guys over there to fame you know go over
there and and uh give give I know
after sitting through what an hour and a
half on the show you know might not have
a whole lot of time to go over there and
sit for the whole thing and that's fine
just go through there and give them a
give him a like at least you know just
get give them a like pop in and then the
moment you guys gotta leave you know
things people got to leave man people
gotta leave but definitely follow dirt
you know I'm hoping we'll have some star
Phil coverage here next week or week
after we'll see you really
um man I'm hoping interesting
interesting look at it because I'm
hoping I get a review code for Starfield
oh okay okay I see and anytime and the
thing is like if that review code is
coming it's got to come next month like
sometime next month
so you know I might I might just
proactively send my and I might just pop
in someone's DM and just have my hand
down can can I have a little please
little food please please are you guys
sit in the British accent and that's a
bloody fool please
I can't say okay wait you know you know
like don't worry about that
all right all right so I've review code
money uh yeah I get it I get it but I
appreciate it for coming through we're
gonna go ahead and head out of here
peace out everybody yeah you know you
guys guys been I I am working on an
intro for the channel
uh so we will the intro okay that's an
intro so we will look into that and I'm
working on updating all the artwork
because I'm putting you in the artwork
so no chocolate thoroughly an artwork
but I appreciate every coming through
definitely go over there and give give
Fame some love man tell them that attic
show sent you